على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
يقول ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
ولا تجسسوا ولا يغتب بعضكم بعضا
قد سبق الكلام
بشيء من الاطناب
والاستطراد
في
وحول ناهي الله سبحانه وتعالى عن التجسس
وقد ذكرنا حدود التجسس
وما يدخل في معناه وايضا ما لا يدخل في
معناه من قد مما قد يتوهمه
بعض الناس
فانتقل الله سبحانه وتعالى من سوء الظن
من الناهي عن سوء الظن
الى الناهي عن التجسس
وبعد ذلك
النهي عن الغيبه
فلاحظنا هذه المناهج الثلاثه وجدناها
مرتبه
يبتدا الامر بسوء الظن ثم التجسس وهو تتبع
الاخطاء ثم الاغتياب
والغيبه
والغيبه ذكر
الاخطاء والهفوات
وما قد يراه المغتاب فيه
اخيه
فسوء الظن نهى الله سبحانه وتعالى عنه
ثم بعد ذلك
انتقل الى النهي عن التجسس وهي خطوه ثانيه
لان التجسس لا يكون
الا مع وجود سوء ظن
الخطوه الاخرى
ان الانسان يتجسس على من اساء به ظنه
لماذا
لان هذه الافكار وهذه الاعتقادات
هذه الامور التي ينهان الله سبحانه وتعالى
عنها من ادران القلوب من مثل
سوء الظن والحقد والعداوه والبغضاء وما
شابه ذلك هذه لا تمكث في القلب دون ان
تؤتي ثمارها الوخيمه
هذه لا تبقى في القلب ولا تحرك ساكنا لا
هي كالسم
تدب في قلب العبد تجاه اخيه
فلا تلبث الا وقد
اتت اكلها وثمارها
ومن ابرز هذه الثمرات
الخبيثه التجسس وهو خلق لئيم
وبعده الغيبه
لان الذي يتجسس
يتجسس
ليشفي ما في صدره على اخيه
ويتجسس من اجل ان يضر اخاه
يريد ان
يوقع به غيره
والانسان اذا اعتقد شيئا
فانه لا يحب ان يكون وحيدا في هذا
الاعتقاد بل يريد ان يكون الناس معه
فاذا ساء الظن باخيه
ثم تجسس فانه سيغتاب
سيذكر هذه المثالب في غيبه اخيه
وهذا اسوا من اللمس لاننا اذا لاحظنا في
الايه السابقه لهذه نهى الله سبحانه
وتعالى عن عن السخريه ونهى سبحانه وتعالى
عنه اللمس والتنابز بالالقاب هذه سيئه
والاسوا من ذلك ان يكون في غيبه
غيبه الذي
اتجه عداوته اليه ان يكون في غيبه اخيه
هذا اسوا لانه حينما يلمسه لامس
او
ينبزه احدا فان ينبزه احد فانه يستطيع ان
يدافع عن نفسه ولكن وهو غائب فانه لا يدري
الا وقد
انتهكت
حرمته والمؤمن محترم عند الله
هذا صحيح يا ابن المجتمع هذه اخلاق
لا توجد في مجتمع محافظ الا
وكانت كالسياج
لهذا المجتمع
ولا يستطيع الشيطان
ولا اعداء هذا المجتمع المحافظ ان يدخل
بين افرادها
لكن
الاهم من ذلك ان هذا من تعظيم المسلم
الله عز وجل عظم المسلم في القران
عظم من قال لا اله الا الله
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ذكر وزاد وكرر
احترام المؤمن
وان احترام المؤمن
المحافظ لدين الله فانه من احترام دين
الله
وتعظيم المؤمن من تعظيم الله سبحانه
وتعالى
يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كما في
السنن ان من اجلال الله تعالى
اكراما ذي الشيبه المسلم
واكرام
الامام العادل
وحامل القران غير الغالي فيه ولا الجاف
عنه
اذا عظمت صاحب القران وهم العلماء ومن
حملوا شيئا من هذا العلم
وكانوا
بين الغلو والتفريط كانوا بين ذلك قواما
فانك تجل تجله واجلالك اياه من اجلال الله
سبحانه وتعالى كذلك المسلم
الذي
شاب راسه وشابت لحيته فيه طاعه الله وفي
هذه الكلمه في كلمه لا اله الا الله فانك
تجله وذلك من اجلال الله
كذلك الامام او الوالي المقسط الذي يقوم
وفي استطاعته ان يظلم ولكنه لا يفعل
تعظيما لله وتعظيما
لحرمات عباد الله فان هذا يجل ومن حقه
وان
كان في قلبك اجلال لامثال هؤلاء وهذا
انواع من المسلمين في الحقيقه فان هذا من
اجلال الله سبحانه وتعالى
كذلك
فان الانسان الذي يحب في الله
وفي المقابل يبغض في الله فهذه كما قال
ابن عباس
اوثق عرى الايمان اوثق عرى الايمان ان تحب
في الله وان تبغض في الله
بان هذا يدل على ان هواك قد انكسر واتجه
مع مشيئه الله ومع اراده الله
وقد جاء في الحديث الذي حسنه جمع من اهل
العلم لا يؤمن
احدكم حتى يكون هواه تبعا لما جئت به هذا
لا يكون الا مع الزمن
والعزيمه والاخلاص لله انه لا يجد في نفسه
صعوبه في كراهيه ما يكرهه الله ولا يجد في
نفسه صعوبه في محبه ما احب الله هذا يدل
على انه قد انغرز
في قلبه وانغرس بذره الايمان في قلبه في
اعماق قلبه
فالمؤمن له حرمه
من قال لا اله الا الله كان محترما في
الارض وفي السماء
تجد ان هذه الاوامر
ولا يغتب بعضكم بعض
وهذا تماما تعريف النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم للغيبه
يقول في حديث
ابن مسعود عند الامام مسلم وهو حديث معروف
يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم اتدرون ما الغيبه
قالوا الله ورسوله اعلم قال ذكرك اخاك بما
يكره هذا هو تعريف الغيب شرعا
ذكرك اخاك يعني المسلم لان المسلم عرضه
محترم
بما يكره هو ان يذكر عنه حتى لو لم تكرهه
انت ان يذكر عنك
ولذلك العلماء
ادخلوا في هذا التعريف اشياء قد لا تخطر
لاحدنا على بال مثل ومثل نووي رحمه الله
في ذكر هذه الاشياء في كتاب الاذكار وهو
باب عظيم ينبغي ان يعتنى به كتاب الاذكار
للامام النووي في ابواب الناهي عن الغيبه
ذكر
ذكر نماذج من الغيبه التي هي
متعاطاه بين الناس وهي عند الله عظيمه
من ذلك يقول النووي رحمه الله ولعلنا
نقراه سويا غدا يقول النووي رحمه الله من
ذلك ذكر كم اخاك الكم ايش يعني الكم يعني
يكون مو كبير شوف الثوب والله الكم كبير
هذه غيبه
وكذلك ذكر ما له من مال
من الدابه ومن البيت حتى لو كان لون البيت
واخوك لا يرضى ان يذكر هذا عنه فانه لا
يجوز
وكذلك ذكر الولد
وذكر الاهل وذكر النسب
كل هذا من الغيبه هذه اشياء قد يستغرب
منها كثيرا من الناس والاسلام بدا غريبا
وسيعود غريبا كما بدا
تكون هذه الغرابه عندما عند اهل الاسلام
اهل الاسلام
قد لا يعرفون دينهم حتى انهم يستغربون ما
هو من ثوابت هذا الدين
وهذه تسمى
فتره
غرابه الاسلام
ان هذا الدين بدا غريبا وسيعود غريبا كما
بدا
ايش يعني يا شيخ ما بقدر اذكر ولا اشي لا
ولا اشي
اذكر الله سبحانه وتعالى
وقد جاء في سير اعلام النبلاء كلمه
لها وقع في قلب منذ ان قراتها قبل بجوز 15
سنه
عن عطاء ابن ابي رباح رحمه الله وهو من
اكابر التابعين
يقول كان الصحابه رضي الله عنهم يرون من
اللغو
الا يرون كل الكلام من اللغو الا ثلاثه
يعني الا ثلث انواع من الكلام
الامر بالمعروف والنهي عن المنكر
وتلاوه شيء من كتاب الله
والنطق فيما لابد منه
الاستقامه المعاش
يعني في الشغل اشياء تتعلق في الدنيا لابد
ان
اتكلم فيها من اجل ان يستقيم عيشي هذه
كانت الكلمات التي تجدها من رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم وصحابته وسوى ذلك فانهم لا
يقولون ويرون ان ذلك ضياع
الغيبه
ماخوذه هذه الكلمه من غابه يغيب
والغائب على وزن الفاعل
ضد الحاضر
والعلماء اختلفوا في حد الغيبه وقد عرفها
لنا رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم في هذا
الحديث الجامع المانع فقال
ذكرك اخاك بما يكره
فنقول الغيبه تعريفها شرعا ذكرك اخاك في
غيبته ما يكره منين اجت كلمه غيبته في
غيبته من نفس الكلمه من ماده الكلمه من
الغين والياء والباء هذه تدل على غياب هذا
المذكور هذه تسمى غيبه وهي من كبائر
الذنوب باجماع العلماء
بان صاحبه متواعد بالنار والعياذ بالله
وسياتي بعض ذلك وطرف منه
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
تبعا لامر الله نهى ناهيا باتا عن غيبه
المسلم
ووقف
في حجته
حينما حج وقال في يوم
النحر وسال الصحابه
قال اي يوم هذا
قال اي اي بلد هذا
اي شهر هذا
فقال ان اموالكم
واعراضكم
ودماءكم عليكم حرام
كحرمه يومكم هذا في بلدكم هذا
في شهركم هذا
يعني هذا اشد التحريم اشد التحريم في
الاسلام يكون على يوم محرم في بلده محرمه
في شهر محرم والمنتهك
حرمته
محرم وهذا يكون دائما لان من قال لا اله
الا الله
فان هذا محترم عند الله
وبعض العلماء اختلفوا في مساله الغيبه
وقالوا الذي هو في القضاء
القضاء يكون
في الدماء
ويكون في الاموال واما في الاعراض فلا
والقرطبي رحمه الله في تفسيره
فانه رد هذا القول ردا شديدا
وذكر ان
من حق المسلم ان يتقاضى في في مسائل العرض
كذلك فان العرض محترم
صحيح هذه مسائل تعين المجتمع المجتمع على
المحافظه لكن اهم من ذلك ما يقوم في القلب
من عباده الله سبحانه وتعالى بتعظيم شعائر
الله وتعظيم ما عظمه الله سبحانه وتعالى
المسلم محترم ومعظم عند الله فانت تقوم
باحترامه وتعظيمه تبعا لتعظيم الله
فان ذلك
لا يزيدك عند الله الا رفعه
ومن يعظم شعائر الله فان ذلك من تقوى
القلوب
من عظم شعائر الله ومن عظم
دين الله سبحانه وتعالى فان تعظيم الدين
لا يكون بتعظيم الدين وحده
تعظيم الدين وتعظيم ماء
ومن كان متاثرا بهذا الدين
ومعظم لهذا معظما لهذا الدين
استمعوا الى هذه الروايه
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
حينما طاف
حينما طاف بالكعبه
قال مخاطبا اياها وذلك ليسمعه
الصحابه والمؤمنون من حوله
فقال ما اعظمك
وما اعظم حرمتك
والذي نفسي بيده لحرمه العبد المؤمن اعظم
عند الله من حرمتك
هذا كلام الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
ذلك لمن
يقول ذلك
ايه عن الكعبه الكعبه
وجاء ايضا في الحديث
بان تنقض
بان تنقض الكعبه حجرا حجرا اهون عند الله
من اراقه
دم امرئ مسلم
وفي الحديث الاخر
والذي نفسي بيده
لو اجتمع اهل السماوات واهل الارض على قتل
مسلم بغير حق لاكبهم الله في النار
يعني هذا بيكون وحده في الجنه وبقيه اهل
السماء والارض في النار
اذا اراقوا دمه بغير حق من الله
فهذه حرمه وهذا طرف من حرمه المسلم
لذلك
كان من المحرمات
كان من كبائر الذنوب
ان
الانسان لا يذكر اخاه بما يكرهه اخوه لا
يذكر اخاه بشيء يتضايق من ذلك بشيء
يجد في قلبه او صدره حرجا منه
وان كنت انت المتكلم
او كنت انا
لا نعبئ بذلك يعني لو واحد ذكر طولي انا
مثلا قد لا يهمني ذلك لكن غيرك يهمه
واذا كان ذلك لا يرضى
حتى لو كان ضحك
بعض الناس تجده
الناس من حوله ويذكرونه باشياء وتنظر في
عينه وتنظر فيه
ابتسامته فتجده متضايقا من ذلك لكنه
مستحيل ان يقول شيئا وبعض الناس يعلل هذه
الاشياء حساس حساس طيب حساس
عرضه
هذا نفس الشيء واحد مثلا
تعتدي على ماله وتقول هذا بخيل هذا ماله
حقه
حقه ان
لا يتنازل عن ماله وحق الا يتنازل عن عرضه
ولا نحن الاحترام بس
وان بزناه بي ما نبرر به افعالنا
مثل حساس او بتحملش وبتحملش مزح طيب الناس
هكذا
ثم اناس لا يعبئون بهذا وثم اناس فعلا
حساسين ما بيحبوا هذا الشيء
فهؤلاء
لهم احترامهم
ولذلك فاننا نبني اعمالنا واقوالنا
على
نبني اقوالنا ونبني
اعمالنا على الحذر
يعني ان كنت شاكا
في هل يرضى هذا القول او لا يرضاه فانك
تسكت لان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لم
ياذن بالكلام الا ما استيقن صاحبه
غيره
ومن كان يؤمن بالله واليوم الاخر فليقل
خيرا او ليصمت
والخير
لفظه
تتضمن اشياء
لابد ان يكون الكلام في نفسه
جيد ولا بد ان يكون في وضعه جيد
لانه ما قال مثلا فليقل صدقا او ليصمت لان
الغيبه هي صدق
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
ذكرك اخاك بما يكره فقال احد الصحابه
ارايت ان كان فيه ما اقول قال ان كان فيه
ما تقول فقد اغتبته
وان لم يكن فيه ما تقول فقد بهته هذا
مصيبه اكبر واكبر
لان البهتان
له
عقاب خاص عند الله جاء فيه سنن ابي داود
من حديث عبد الله بن عمر ان النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم قال
ومن قال في مسلم ما ليس فيه
حبسه الله في ردغه الخبالي حتى يخرج مما
قال
ايش ردغه الخبال
ردغه الخبال يقول
الاجر رحمه الله ردغه الخبال يعني مكان
وسخ اهل النار
مكان حيث يستجمع هذا المكان
اوساخ اهل النار من البول والغائط والدم
العرق وهذه الاشياء
فانها تستجمع في مكان في نار جهنم والعياذ
بالله هذا المكان يسمى رضغه الخباله فالذي
يقول في مسلم ما ليس فيه حبسه الله في
ردغه الخبالي حتى يخرج مما قال
هذه مساله عاديه جدا عند الناس وهذا
للجاهل جهل الناس
يعني انا اسالكم مثلا
ايهما اعظم عند الله
انه الانسان
يلبس ذهب ولا انسان يغتاب مسلم
يعني مثلا نتصور هذه المساله
لو دخل علينا اخ او دخل على مجلس
ووجدناه محلا بالذهب لابس الذهب على
عنقه وعلى اصابعه وهكذا
فانه
ينكر عليه
قال هذا محرم في الاسلام وهذا لا يجوز على
الرجال
لكن لو جلس
اخر في المجلس نفسه
واغتاب ربع ساعه نص ساعه او كان كل كلام
مغيبه قال لما تجد
احدا من عباد الله
ينهاه عن ذلك وهذا للجاهل الذي نزل في
الناس وايضا
فالتاثر
باهل البطاله واهل الكفر الكفار لا حرمه
لاحد منهم على احد
ما في حرمه
ولذلك
يستهزؤون ويضحكون ويتحكمون على الملا
برسمه رسمات
لكبرائهم ولاخرين من
اهل شعبهم بل قد يكون
عظيما في دينهم
كونوا قسا مثلا او يكون عالما او يكون او
يرسموهم منخاروا هالكد وذنيها الكد وبحكي
هبل
لانه هذه عادته
فالمسلمون قال لك لا احنا برضو بنرسم
وياخذ
السفهاء منا يرسم العلماء
يقسم العلماء بما ليس فيهم ويتحكم بهم
وهكذا وهذا لا يجوز لادنانا
على كل حال الغيبه حرمها الله وقال ولا
يغتب بعضكم بعضا
ثم ضرب مثلا لنا في ذلك في حرمه هذا
المسلم
وقال ايحب احدكم
ان ياكل لحم اخيه ميتا فكرهتم
فهذا اعظم ناهي
عن الغيبه صحيح في احاديث مهوله
واحوال لاهل الغيبه قد ناتي على طرف منها
ولكنها لا تبلغ فيه شده النهي ما بلغت هذه
الايه كيف ذلك يقول اي يحب احدكم ان ياكل
لحم اخيه ميتا يعني مثله مثل عرضه
بلحمه يعني الله عز وجل يقول ايحب احدكم
ان ياكل لحم اخيه وهو في الحقيقه لا ياكل
اللحم وانما العرف فالله عز وجل جعل عرض
المسلم
بمنزله دمه ولحمه
فكما اننا لا نعتدي على المسلمين
في دمائهم فكذلك اعراضهم محترمه
وكذلك قال ميتا لانه غائب لا يستطيع ان
يدافع عن نفسه ولا يستطيع ان ينفي ولا
يستطيع ان ينكر ينكر ولا يستطيع فالذي
يتناول عرض اخاه في غيبته فانه بمنزله من
اكل لحمه ميتا
وفي هذه الايه قراءتان ايحب احدكم ان ياكل
لحم اخيه ميتا وميتا
وكلاهما بمعنى
يقول تعالى فكرهتم هنا لطيفه جميله جدا
ايش يعني فكرهتم
يقول العلماء هذه الفاه
فكرهتموه هذه تسمى عند النحاب بالفاء
الفصيحه
ايش الفاء الفصيحه فاء الفصيحه
تاتي في لغه العرب
في جواب شرط مقدر او مذكور لكن هنا مقدر
فكان الله سبحانه وتعالى قال جملتين في
جمله واحده فقال
فكرهتموه يعني في شرط وكلام مقدر ما ذكره
لكن افطرنا له بالفاعل فاء الفضيحه
فكان تقدير الكلام
عرض عليكم ذلك فكرهتموه
فكذلك انتهوا
عن هذا الفعل هذه الغيبه يعني العقل
السليم
فطر السليمه لا ترضى انها تتناول من لحم
البني ادم
شيء النفوس
المعتدله
فانها تنفر من ذلك
وهي مجبوله على ذلك
فاذا كرهنا ذلك
فلتكن كراهيتنا لتلك
كراهيتنا لهذه فكما اننا نكره ان ناكل
الميته
ميته البني ادم فكذلك
لا يرضى والتنفر النفوس الزكيه من اكل عرض
المسلم
نفس نفس الاستنكار ونفس النفور
وبعض العلماء استدل بهذه الايه
يعني اريكم الى اي حد العلماء اخذوا هذه
هذا النهي
استدل بعض العلماء
في هذه الايه على تحريم اكل لحم المسلم
الميت حتى لو كان في ضروره
ومثاله واحد ماشي اثنين ماشيين في صحراء
واحد منهم هلك والاخر
مضطر حتى
يبقى حيا قال بعض العلماء استدلالا بهذه
الايه انه يهلك ولا ياكل
وهذا وان كان فيه
نوع ضعف في الاستدلال الا ان ذلك يدل على
عظمه عرض المسلم في دين الاسلام
وان شاء الله
نواصل الكلام غدا باذن الله والله اعلم
وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين